An apple, nobody gives their teacher an apple anymore. In her first year of teaching first grade, here are the sorts of things that Mindy got from her kids.
苹果，现在没人给老师送苹果了。这是明迪教一年级的第一年，以下是她从孩子们那里收到的一些礼物。
A typical first grader will bring me things that would range from students that wrapped up their old McDonald toys, a pencil from the dollar store wrapped up. Some people sent in homemade cookies, which is very sweet.
一般的一年级学生带给我的东西五花八门，有学生用包装纸包好旧麦当劳玩具，还有从一元店买来的铅笔。有些人送来家常饼干，这非常贴心。
So last Christmas, the day before vacation, she has all the kids sitting on the carpet. And some of them have presents for her that they're all excited for her to open. And she has treats for them. And all the kids want to be picked. And they're raising their hands.
去年圣诞节前一天，假期前的最后一天，她让所有的孩子坐在地毯上。其中一些孩子带了礼物给她，他们都兴奋地等着她拆开。她也为他们准备了零食。所有的孩子都想被选中，他们纷纷举手。
So I have one student sitting so quietly and so anxious. So I call on him, and brings me up this bag. I start opening it. Like, oh, this is great.
有个学生坐得非常安静，看起来很焦急。所以我叫了他，他把这个袋子递给我。我开始打开它。我想，噢，这太棒了。
I pull out these black slippers with little silver speckles. And on the top, there's that puffy fssh, fssh kind of material, the real soft and feathery type of thing. And on the front of the slipper, in bright red cursive writing, they say "Playerette," with a little Playboy bunny on the back of the slipper.
我拿出一双带有银色小亮片的黑色拖鞋。鞋面上有一种毛茸茸的材质，看起来软绵绵、毛绒绒的。在拖鞋的前面，用亮红色的草书写着“Playerette”，拖鞋后面还有一个小小的花花公子兔标志。
So I pull these out, and I'm like, oh, aren't these fancy? And they all start chanting, 27 six-year-olds, put 'em on, put 'em on, put 'em on! And they're all just cheering and shouting. And the kid's face, he was so proud and so excited about the slippers. But in my head, I'm thinking, did the parents have no idea?
我把这些拿出来，说，噢，这些不是很时髦吗？他们开始齐声喊叫，27个六岁小孩喊着：穿上它，穿上它，穿上它！他们都在欢呼叫喊。那个孩子的脸看起来非常自豪，对这双拖鞋兴奋不已。但在我脑海里，我想的是，难道家长们完全不知道吗？
Do you think, from a kid point of view, when they saw the slippers, they just read them as fancy?
你认为从孩子的角度来看，当他们看到这双拖鞋时，他们只是觉得它很时髦吗？
Oh, absolutely.
噢，绝对是这样。
That's what it was.
事情就是这样。
They had no idea that they said Playerette. They had no idea, at least, I don't think that they had any idea what the bunny would have represented. All they saw was fancy black slippers, silver sparkles, fuzzy things.
他们根本不知道上面写着“Playerette”。他们不知道，至少我认为他们完全不知道那个兔子的标志代表什么。他们看到的只是时髦的黑拖鞋、银色亮片和毛茸茸的东西。
That's what I love about this so much, is that it wasn't just one kid's judgment that this is the perfect present, that it's the entire class of six-year-olds. Like we might disagree on other things, but there is one thing that we can agree on.
这就是我如此喜欢这个故事的原因，因为这不仅仅是一个孩子的判断，认为这是完美的礼物，而是整整一个班的六岁孩子都这么认为。我们可能在其他事情上有分歧，但有一件事我们是可以达成共识的。
Oh yeah. It wasn't just a boy or a girl or a couple of kids. It was the whole class shouting, cheering.
噢，是的。这不仅仅是一个男孩或一个女孩或者几个孩子的行为。是全班同学都在大喊、欢呼。
After school that day, as you might expect, Mindy nearly runs down the hall with her new slippers, eager to share the magic with a fellow first grade teacher.
那天放学后，不出所料，明迪几乎是跑着穿过走廊去见她的新拖鞋，急着和另一位一年级老师分享这份“魔力”。
So I'm walking down the hall, knock on her door. You're never going to believe what one of my students gave me today. I walk in. I put the slippers on. She says, oh yeah? She pulls out her little lovely gift, some lingerie. And I literally, hhhuu, gasp.
我走在走廊里，敲了敲她的门。“你永远不会相信今天我的学生给了我什么。”我走进去，穿上拖鞋。她说：“噢，是吗？”然后她拿出了她收到的可爱礼物——一些内衣。我当时真的，“呼”，倒吸一口凉气。
The actual lingerie?
真的是内衣？
Yeah.
是的。
What was it?
是什么样的？
A thong and a little tank top.
一条丁字裤和一件小背心。
Wait, a first grader gave her teacher or his teacher a thong and a tank top?
等等，一个一年级学生给老师送了一条丁字裤和一件背心？
Yeah. Yes.
是的。没错。
Was it sexy? Or was it cotton, like, cute girl?
是性感的吗？还是像可爱少女那种棉质的？
I would say cute girl.
我会说是可爱少女风格的。
I say this as if it makes any difference at all. It's still a thong.
我这么说好像能有什么区别似的。它依然是一条丁字裤。
Yeah. At what point, exactly, are you in the store, or shopping online, whatever you're doing, at what point is that something that's OK to give your teacher, is what I'd like to know. Do you agree? Am I a little bit out of line?
是的。我真想知道，当你身处商店或是网上购物时，到底在什么情况下，你会觉得送这种东西给老师是合适的？你同意吗？我这样说是不是有点越界了？
No, I think all of America, well, not all of America, but I think many people are with you on this, including me.
不，我想全美国，好吧，不是全美国，但我认为很多人和你看法一致，包括我在内。
OK. Because at that point, when she held them-- and then I'm thinking, when they're looking through the sizes, are they checking you out?
好的。因为当她拿出那些东西的时候——我在想，当他们在挑选尺码时，他们是在打量你吗？
And that's clearly something that the parents helped order, yes?
那显然是家长帮忙订购的，对吧？
Oh yeah.
噢，是的。
The parents were in on that.
家长们参与了这件事。
I would say the parents completely ordered that.
我会说这绝对是家长们订购的。
It seems like that would be kind of an uncomfortable parent-teacher meeting after that.
那之后的家长会可能会变得相当尴尬。
If I was dating somebody, and they gave me a thong, and I hadn't known them that long, or we'd only been dating a short period of time, that would be like, OK, how inappropriate, right?
如果我在和某人约会，而他们送我一条丁字裤，而我认识他们没多久，或者我们交往的时间很短，那我会觉得：天哪，这太不合适了，对吧？
OK, maybe this is the kind of etiquette question that we should all already know the answer to, but I have to say, I found it kind of a stumper. You're a first grade teacher, and the parents of your students buy you a thong, or slippers that say Playerette on them, not the right kind of gift for a teacher, you think. So is it impolite to actually say something to them about it? Or do you just accept graciously? Both teachers, in this case, accepted graciously.
好吧，也许这就是我们所有人都应该已经知道答案的礼仪问题，但我得说，我觉得这真是个难题。你是小学一年级老师，学生的家长给你买了一条丁字裤，或者写着“Playerette”的拖鞋，你觉得这不适合作为送给老师的礼物。那么，实际上对他们说些什么是不礼貌的吗？还是你只能委婉地接受？在这种情况下，两位老师都委婉地接受了。
So I, yeah, when I was writing out my thank-yous to my students, I just said, thank you for the thoughtful gift. It was greatly appreciated. And I leave it at that, I guess, not really make it more of an embarrassing or strange, awkward situation.
所以，当我写感谢信给学生时，我只是说，谢谢你们体贴的礼物。非常感谢。我想就这样吧，不要让它变成一种更尴尬、更奇怪、更局促的局面。
Perhaps there was a time when social rules were clear, when people knew what to say and do in certain situations. But the world changes fast. There are constantly new situations out there that leave us all improvising, inventing our own rules of propriety. And that's the subject of today's program. We have three stories of people forced to figure out how to maintain some decency and dignity in the face of some very unsettling situations. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
也许曾经有一段时间，社会规则是很明确的，人们知道在特定情况下该说什么、做什么。但世界变化太快了。不断有新的情况出现，让我们所有人都在即兴创作，发明属于自己的礼仪规则。而这正是今天节目的主题。我们有三个关于人们被迫在面对一些非常令人不安的情况时，试图维持体面和尊严的故事。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，《美国生活》节目，由公共广播国际公司分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Act One of our program today, Governments Say the Darnedest Things. In that act, government officials who want nothing more than a little civility, thank you very much, even when the facts contradict a lot of what they're saying. Act Two, Dems Gone Wild, in which a Republican tries to run for local office in a very Democratic district in New Jersey, evoking some rather disturbing behavior from his friends and neighbors. Act Three, Swiss Near Miss, a woman follows the rules of propriety. A man does not. Stay with us.
我们节目的第一幕，“政府说最惊人的话”。在那一幕中，政府官员们除了想要一点礼貌之外别无所求，即使事实与他们所说的许多内容相矛盾。第二幕，“失控的民主党人”，讲述了一个共和党人在新泽西州一个非常倾向民主党的选区竞选地方公职的故事，引来了他的朋友和邻居们一些相当令人不安的行为。第三幕，“瑞士险情”，一位女士遵循了礼仪规则，而一位男士没有。请继续收听。
Act One, The Government Says the Darnedest Things. There is a part of our government that is charged with enforcing politeness as a matter of law. And that's the Federal Communication Commission, which, among other things, has the thankless job of deciding which words and images can be put on radio and television. As you probably heard, there has been a new crackdown on indecency at the FCC in recent months. And the case that represents the biggest break with the past has to do with the singer Bono getting an award at the Golden Globes and saying "F-ing brilliant" on national television.
第一幕，“政府说最惊人的话”。我们政府中有一部分职责是作为法律问题来强制执行礼貌。那就是联邦通信委员会（FCC），它除了其他职责外，还承担着一项吃力不讨好的工作，即决定哪些词汇和图像可以出现在广播和电视上。正如你可能听到的那样，近几个月来，FCC对不雅内容的打击力度加大。而代表着与过去最大决裂的案件，与歌手波诺在金球奖颁奖典礼上获奖时，在国家电视台上说了句“F-ing brilliant（他妈的太棒了）”有关。
In the past, the FCC has said that these fleeting, gratuitous uses of the F-word are harmless. But in a landmark decision, it declared, back in March, that they were changing the rules. And what's not been talked about much is the reasons that they give for this change. These reasons get to the very heart of what polite society means, here on the radio, or in television. The FCC said, basically, the F-word must be stopped in nearly all instances, because first and foremost, it harms children. So we wanted to check with an expert to find out if, in fact, there is any scientific evidence that bad words hurt kids.
在过去，FCC曾表示，这种转瞬即逝、无端使用F开头的词是无害的。但在三月份的一项里程碑式的决定中，它宣布正在改变规则。而人们谈论不多的是他们给出这一改变的理由。这些理由触及了礼貌社会在这里，在广播或电视上究竟意味着什么的核心。FCC基本上说，F开头的词在几乎所有情况下都必须被禁止，因为首先，它会伤害儿童。所以我们想咨询一位专家，看看是否真的有任何科学证据表明脏话会伤害孩子。
The Wall Street Journal called me the preeminent scholar of profanity. And the Boston Globe called me Dr. Dirty Words.
《华尔街日报》称我为亵渎语言领域的杰出学者。《波士顿环球报》称我为“脏话博士”。
His other name, the one his mom gave him, is Timothy Jay, a professor of psychology and author of academic books with titles like Cursing in America and Why We Curse. A warning to listeners that in his interview, we mention directly and indirectly a number of curse words. He turns out to be very familiar with the basis of this FCC ruling.
他的另一个名字，他母亲给他取的名字，是蒂莫西·杰，一位心理学教授，著有像《美国的诅咒》和《为什么我们诅咒》等学术书籍。提醒听众，在他的采访中，我们直接或间接地提到了许多诅咒词汇。事实证明，他对FCC这一裁决的基础非常熟悉。
Our whole obscenity law is predicated on this idea that exposure to obscene material will deprave or corrupt children. And we've had that in our law since the 1600s. But there's no evidence that a word, in and of itself, harms someone.
我们整个淫秽法都是建立在这个理念之上的，即接触淫秽材料会使儿童堕落或腐败。自1600年代以来，我们的法律中一直有这一条。但没有任何证据表明一个词本身会伤害某人。
So what studies exist? What do we know about children and curse words, and what it does to them?
那么存在哪些研究呢？关于儿童和诅咒词汇，以及它对他们有什么影响，我们了解多少？
I've done a number of studies over the years where we've gone into daycares, and we've collected what kids say to each other, kind of unobtrusively. I've also had informants go who worked in summer camps, and we just write down everything that happens. We carry these little 3x5 cards around and write down the who, what, where, and when. And by and large, every normal kid knows how to swear. As soon as kids learn how to talk-- we've got two-year-olds in our sample saying four-letter words. And a lot of times, they don't know what they're saying. But they are repeating what their parents and siblings say.
多年来我做过许多研究，我们走进日托中心，悄悄收集孩子们彼此之间说的话。我还派了在夏令营工作的线人去，我们只是写下发生的一切。我们随身带着这些3x5的小卡片，记录下谁、什么、哪里和什么时候。总的来说，每个正常的孩子都知道如何咒骂。一旦孩子们学会说话——我们的样本中就有两岁的孩子在说四个字母的脏话。很多时候，他们并不明白自己在说什么，但他们在重复父母和兄弟姐妹说的话。
Reading Timothy Jay's studies is the kind of experience that simultaneously makes you feel hopeful and hopeless about the very idea of social science. The daycare and summer camp data are broken down into pages of charts, listing dozens of curse words, and breakdowns of who says what at what age, and what kind of situation they're saying it in. The single most popular curse word, by a huge margin, no other word is even close, among children age 5 to 12, is the F-word, starting around age 5, followed by the S-word, when they are about 7. Suck, damn, and Jesus get a lot of play in the summer camp data. Hell, bitch, bum, and ass do pretty well in the daycare data.
阅读蒂莫西·杰的研究是一种既让你对社会科学本身感到充满希望又感到绝望的体验。日托中心和夏令营的数据被细分成几页图表，列出了数十个诅咒词汇，并细分了谁在什么年龄、在什么情况下说这些话。在5到12岁的儿童中，最受欢迎的诅咒词汇，以巨大的优势领先，没有其他词汇能与之相提并论，那就是F开头的词，从5岁左右开始，其次是S开头的词，在他们大约7岁时。在夏令营数据中，“Suck”、“Damn”和“Jesus”的使用率很高。在日托数据中，“Hell”、“Bitch”、“Bum”和“Ass”表现也不错。
I just did a sample of 200 college students and asked them about what their parents did when they swore, and how they learned how to swear, and whether they were punished or not. And 96%, 97% of these kids grew up swearing. And most of their parents had rules against swearing, but most of their parents swore anyway in the house. And so everybody knows how to do this, swearing, and almost all kids do. And it goes on day after day with very little consequence, very little harm.
我刚刚对200名大学生进行了抽样调查，询问了他们的父母在咒骂时是怎么做的，他们是如何学会咒骂的，以及他们是否受到了惩罚。这些孩子中有96%到97%是在咒骂的环境中长大的。他们的大多数父母在家里都有禁止咒骂的规矩，但他们大多数人无论如何都会在家里咒骂。所以每个人都知道怎么做，咒骂，几乎所有的孩子都会。这日复一日地发生，却几乎没有什么后果，几乎没有造成什么伤害。
Let me just read to you from the recent FCC decision about Bono using the F-word. FCC Commissioner Kathleen Abernathy said about the decision against using the F-word at the Golden Globes, she said "Today we take a strong stand against indecency on our public airwaves, and a significant step in protecting our children." What's your take on that?
让我读一下最近FCC关于波诺使用F词的决定。FCC委员凯瑟琳·阿伯纳西在谈到禁止在金球奖上使用F词的决定时说：“今天，我们对公共广播中的不雅行为采取了强硬立场，这是保护我们儿童的重要一步。”你对此有何看法？
Most seven-year-olds already know what that word is. Most four-year-olds have heard it. I don't know what you're protecting them from. And most kids use this kind of language.
大多数七岁孩子已经知道那个词是什么了。大多数四岁孩子都听过它。我不知道你在保护他们免受什么伤害。而且大多数孩子都会使用这种语言。
I'm not going to lie. I've said some of them out loud. I hear it all the time in the hall and stuff. And I guess I'm used to it.
我不撒谎。我大声说过其中的一些。我在走廊里经常听到这些。我想我已经习惯了。
When one of our producers, Lisa Pollak, went out and talked to kids around Chicago, aged 9 to 12, in their schools, they pretty much confirmed everything that Timothy Jay had seen. Bad words are everywhere.
当我们的制片人丽莎·波拉克去芝加哥采访9到12岁的孩子时，他们在学校里基本上证实了蒂莫西·杰所见的一切。脏话无处不在。
I get mad at my parents sometimes when they say it, because I have two younger siblings. And I think that it's just better if, for little kids, they don't learn it when they're younger.
我有时会对父母说脏话感到生气，因为我有两个更小的弟弟妹妹。我认为，对于小孩子来说，最好不要让他们在更小的时候就学会这些。
What age do you think when you say little kids? What age is OK to know those words?
你认为当你提到“小孩子”时是指什么年龄？几岁知道这些词是可以接受的？
I think that around when you get in, maybe, third grade or fourth grade, that's a good age to actually know what the words mean. Because you're smarter.
我认为大约在你上三年级或四年级的时候，那是一个真正知道这些词含义的好年龄。因为你变得更聪明了。
Do you think there are any kids today who haven't heard these words?
你认为今天有没有还没听过这些词的孩子？
Probably a newborn baby, like a new newborn baby that's still in your mom's stomach, but well, the babies that can't talk probably know it but just can't talk, I think.
可能刚出生的婴儿吧，就像还在妈妈肚子里那种刚出生的婴儿，但好吧，那些还不会说话的婴儿可能也知道，只是不会说，我想。
Now to be clear, these are very simple studies. They don't follow the kids who use more curse words for years, and then try to find out if their lives turned out differently than the kids who use fewer curse words. All the research can show so far is that most kids use these words, even if they think that it's wrong to use them, even if sometimes they aren't totally sure what certain words mean. And the research also shows that kids use the words in exactly the same way that adults do, in moments of frustration, or for emphasis, or in moments of surprise, or in jokes, or in anger. No difference.
现在要明确的是，这些是非常简单的研究。他们没有追踪那些使用更多脏话的孩子多年，看看他们的生活是否与那些使用较少脏话的孩子不同。目前所有研究能显示的只是，大多数孩子都会使用这些词，即使他们认为使用这些词是错误的，即使有时他们并不完全确定某些词的含义。研究还表明，孩子们使用这些词的方式与成年人完全相同，在沮丧、强调、惊讶、开玩笑或愤怒的时刻。没有区别。
Like when I get into a bad mood, because my cousin, he broke something of mine yesterday, and I had got mad. And I didn't mean to curse and it just slipped out. And I said, you F-ing idiot, you broke my D stuff. And then I had got in trouble.
就像当我心情不好时，因为我的表弟昨天弄坏了我的东西，我很生气。我不是故意要咒骂，但它脱口而出。我说，你这个F开头的白痴，你弄坏了我的D东西。然后我就惹上麻烦了。
When you're in an argument with somebody, and they take it too far, and then you just want to say, dude, what the H is your problem? Or there's just things you want to say.
当你和某人争吵时，他们做得太过分了，然后你只想说，伙计，你TMD到底有什么问题？或者有些话你就是想说出来。
I think I used the first curse word when I was eight, because someone got me real mad and I was in an argument with my friend. And then I was like, you F-in' B, why don't you get out of my F-in' face?
我想我第一次用脏话是在八岁的时候，因为有人让我非常生气，我和朋友在争吵。然后我就说，你这个F开头的B，你为什么不从我面前消失？
What did it feel like to use those words for the first time?
第一次说这些词是什么感觉？
Well, sort of, I felt relieved, because she actually listened to me. She actually got out of my face.
嗯，某种程度上，我感到如释重负，因为她真的听了我的话。她真的从我面前消失了。
You cuss when you hurt yourself and it really hurts. I'm sure you cuss, don't you? Do you?
当你伤害自己而且真的很痛时，你会咒骂。我相信你会咒骂，不是吗？你会吗？
I have been known to cuss.
众所周知，我会咒骂。
Because you can. You're an adult. You have to let yourself free sometimes.
因为你可以。你是个成年人。你有时必须让自己自由。
This has great relevance to the law. In the past, the Supreme Court has said that the FCC is right to keep words off radio and television, if hearing the words could, quote, "enlarge the child's vocabulary in an instant." And that's one of the justifications cited by the FCC in the Bono decision. Quote, "We believe that even isolated broadcasts of the F-word in situations such as that here could do so as well, in a manner that many, if not most, parents would find highly detrimental and objectionable."
这与法律有很大关系。过去，最高法院曾表示，如果听到这些词可能会“瞬间扩大孩子的词汇量”，FCC有权将这些词排除在广播和电视之外。这也是FCC在波诺决定中引用的理由之一。引用：“我们认为，即使是像这里这样的情况下，零星广播F开头的词也可能产生同样的效果，以一种许多（如果不是大多数）家长会认为极其有害和令人反感的方式。”
I'm not even sure that most parents would find it detrimental. If you've got 60% of your parents using this kind of language in the home, why would it be more detrimental to hear it on TV than to hear your mom or dad say that kind of stuff?
我甚至不确定大多数家长会觉得它有害。如果你家中有60%的家长在家里使用这种语言，为什么在电视上听到它会比听到你爸爸妈妈说这种话更有害呢？
Has anybody studied the actual thing that the FCC is regulating, which is, what is the effect of seeing certain words or seeing certain things referred to on television and radio? What is the effect of that on children's development and behavior?
有没有人研究过FCC正在监管的实际事物，即在电视和广播中看到某些词汇或提到某些事物有什么影响？这对儿童的发展和行为有什么影响？
The closest we've come to that, there's people who have been studying the effects of kids watching violent television and playing violent video games. And the closest they get to language is looking at rap music and the lyrics in rap music. And those studies show it doesn't have harm like watching violence. That's been clearly linked, correlated with later incidents of verbal or physical aggression, but words, no.
我们最接近的研究是那些研究儿童观看暴力电视和玩暴力电子游戏影响的研究。在语言方面最接近的是关注说唱音乐及其歌词。这些研究表明它不像观看暴力那样有伤害。这已经被清楚地联系并与后来的言语或身体攻击事件相关联，但词汇，则没有。
The Commission in this decision said-- I'm reading from their decision-- "The F-word is one of the most vulgar, graphic, and explicit descriptions of sexual activity in the English language. Its use invariably invokes a coarse sexual image." The implication of this is that when Bono says F-ing brilliant, the five commissioners of the FCC actually are picturing penises and vaginas. "Its use invariably invokes a course sexual image." Is there any evidence that when people say F-ing brilliant, or use the F-word in this kind of way, that anyone else in America is picturing a coarse sexual image?
委员会在这个决定中说——我正在阅读他们的决定——“F开头的词是英语中对性行为最粗俗、最图形化和最明确的描述之一。它的使用总是会引起粗俗的性形象。”这隐含的意思是，当波诺说“F-ing brilliant（他妈的太棒了）”时，FCC的五位委员实际上是在脑海中构想阴茎和阴道。“它的使用总是会引起粗俗的性形象。”有任何证据表明，当人们说“F-ing brilliant”或以这种方式使用F开头的词时，美国还有其他人会想到粗俗的性形象吗？
Well, no. I have done my Master's thesis and dissertation on how people interpret taboo words. And usually, we think of them connotatively. So you do think of the emotional overtones of the word. You don't think of it in its denotative meaning. That's one of the unique things about this word. If you said, the F-ing good convention, people wouldn't think it was a convention where you had intercourse. They would think it meant it was a really good convention. F-ing brilliant doesn't bring up what the word denotes. It brings up the emotional feeling behind it. That's why we use this kind of language, because it's emotional.
嗯，没有。我关于人们如何解读禁忌词的硕士论文和博士论文就是做的这个。通常，我们从内涵上思考它们。所以你确实会想到这个词的情感色彩。你不会想到它的外延含义。这是这个词独特的地方之一。如果你说，“这F开头的好的会议”，人们不会认为这是一场你要进行性行为的会议。他们会认为这意味着这真的是一场很好的会议。“F-ing brilliant”不会引出这个词所指代的内容，它引出了背后的情感。这就是为什么我们使用这种语言，因为它是情绪化的。
Do you have any sympathy for the idea that there's a general coarsening of the culture that's happened, more graphic stuff on movies and television and on radio, and that that is not an entirely desirable thing?
对于文化普遍粗俗化，电影、电视和广播中出现了更多图形化的东西，而这并非完全令人向往的事情，你对此有什么同情吗？
I have no sympathy for that whatsoever. I've been asked that question for 30 years. It's the same question, aren't we going to hell in a handbasket because somebody said the F-word. But I don't know what people thought the common people talked in Chaucer's time or Shakespeare's time. I think this language has been around forever. On the other hand, I think we're a more civil society. We have laws now against harassment at work and discrimination at work, where racial minorities and women were excluded from a lot of places in our culture.
我对此一点同情都没有。30年来我一直被问这个问题。这是同一个问题，“难道我们不是因为某人说了F开头的词就要完蛋了吗？”但我不知道人们认为乔叟时代或莎士比亚时代的普通百姓是怎么谈话的。我认为这种语言一直存在。另一方面，我认为我们是一个更文明的社会。我们现在有禁止职场骚扰和职场歧视的法律，而种族少数群体和女性在我们的文化中曾经被排斥在许多地方之外。
Wait, you're saying there's more civility now than there was 100, 200 years ago.
等等，你是说现在的文明程度比100、200年前更高？
Yeah. I don't think swearing is part of some coarsening trend.
是的。我不认为咒骂是某种粗俗化趋势的一部分。
If Timothy Jay is right, what it means is that most of our current law and Supreme Court decisions about indecency are based on some very unscientific notions of what bad words and images do to kids. And we wanted to discuss all this with one of the FCC commissioners, or FCC Chairman Michael Powell. The commissioners that we contacted declined our invitations to appear.
如果蒂莫西·杰是对的，这意味着我们目前关于不雅的大多数法律和最高法院判决，都是基于一些关于坏词和图像对孩子产生什么影响的非常不科学的观念。我们想与FCC的一位委员或FCC主席迈克尔·鲍威尔讨论所有这些。我们联系的委员拒绝了我们的采访邀请。
But Chairman Powell's legal adviser, John Cody, said, sure. And we started with the studies. If there's no evidence that even repeated exposure to bad words hurts kids, I asked him, why ban these words?
但鲍威尔主席的法律顾问约翰·科迪说，没问题。我们从研究开始谈起。如果没有任何证据表明即使反复接触脏话也会伤害孩子，我问他，为什么要禁止这些词？
You know, Ira, I think you're right. At the end of the day, we haven't, as a Commission, or nor do I think, as a government, seen very many studies that have documented the causal link between indecency and its impact on children. It's kind of hard for the Federal Communications Commission to have to weigh what its actual impact is on children. And that's more of Congress's job. For us, we have a law that's been in place for 70 years that we, by statute, are forced to implement. And our hands are a little tied in the area, and in all areas in which our job is to enforce the laws that Congress writes.
你知道，艾拉，我认为你是对的。归根结底，作为一个委员会，或者我认为作为一个政府，我们没有看到很多研究记录了不雅行为与其对儿童影响之间的因果关系。联邦通信委员会很难权衡它对儿童的实际影响是什么。那是国会的工作。对于我们来说，我们有一部已经实施了70年的法律，根据法规，我们被迫执行。在这方面，以及在我们有责任执行国会制定的法律的所有领域中，我们的手脚都有点束缚。
Let's talk about the Golden Globes decision. And I understand that you can only talk about this to a limited extent, because you guys have a kind of appeal that's up in front of the Commission still, right? OK, just to review for people what happens in that case. Bono gets this award at an awards show. He uses the F-word.
让我们谈谈金球奖的决定。我知道你只能在有限的范围内谈论这个问题，因为你们在委员会面前还有一种上诉，对吧？好的，只是为了回顾一下案件中发生了什么。波诺在颁奖典礼上获得了这个奖项。他用了F开头的词。
And the FCC says, basically, the F-word deserves special treatment and special restrictions in its use. And the reason that it gives in the decision is this. "The F-word is one of the most vulgar, graphic, and explicit descriptions of sexual activity in the English language. Its use invariably invokes a coarse sexual image." It seems like what the commissioners are saying is that when Bono says "F-ing brilliant," they're saying that the problem with this word, and the reason why it deserves special scrutiny under law, is that literally, they're picturing an actual act.
FCC基本上说，F开头的词在其使用中应该得到特殊对待和特殊限制。它在决定中给出的理由是这样的：“F开头的词是英语中对性行为最粗俗、最图形化和最明确的描述之一。它的使用总是会引起粗俗的性形象。”看起来委员们是在说，当波诺说“F-ing brilliant”时，他们说这个词的问题，以及它为什么在法律下值得特殊审查的原因，是字面上，他们是在构想一个实际的行为。
Right. I don't know that it's what they picture. I think part of that decision, though, is that the word in and of itself, maybe for the young who think about it, that's what it means.
对。我不知道那是他们所构想的。但我认为那个决定的一部分是，这个词本身，也许对那些考虑它的年轻人来说，就是那个意思。
But the rationale is so strange. They're saying that the reason why it's important to do it is because the use of this word in any context invokes this coarse sexual image. And if you think about how it's used, for example, Pat Tillman, the football player who was killed in Iraq, his brother at a memorial service, saying, he's F-ing dead. So that clearly does not invoke a coarse sexual image for anyone. And so the premise of the ruling seems to be questionable.
但这个基本原理太奇怪了。他们说，之所以有必要这样做，是因为这个词在任何环境下的使用都会引起这种粗俗的性形象。如果你想想它是如何被使用的，例如，在伊拉克阵亡的足球运动员帕特·蒂尔曼，他在追悼会上，他的兄弟说，“他TMD死了。”所以这对任何人来说显然都不会引起粗俗的性形象。因此，该裁决的前提似乎是值得怀疑的。
Well, part of that is, to be frank, as I think NBC argued, and some of the recon petitions argued, and we will have to look at again, when these words are used as intensifiers, as opposed to in a sexual context. But I think you're right. The Commission, at that point, felt, boy, when you use this word, and you're a kid, I don't know that there is such a thing as an intensifier. I think it is the utmost, it is the word at the top of the list. And that is kind of the basis of the decision.
嗯，说实话，部分原因是，正如我认为NBC所争辩的，以及一些重新审议请愿书所争辩的，我们将不得不再次审视这一点，当这些词被用作强化词时，而不是在性语境下。但我认为你是对的。委员会在那时觉得，天哪，当你使用这个词时，如果你是个孩子，我不知道是否有“强化词”这种东西。我认为它是最重要的，它是列表顶部的词。这算是该决定的基础。
It's kind of a weird justification.
这是一种奇怪的理由。
Again, and that will be the subject of the recon.
再次重申，这将是重新审议的主题。
The recon, that is the petition for reconsideration. As you point out here that the FCC's own staff initially ruled that when Bono said "F-ing brilliant," it did not have any sexual connotation, and for that reason, it was not indecent. And it was the commissioners, the guys at the top, who went back and reopened the case, at the urging of a lobbying group, declared that "F-ing brilliant" means sex. We did ask the 9 to 12 year olds we interviewed around Chicago what Bono might mean by the phrase "F-ing brilliant." None of them saw it the way the commissioners did.
重新审议，那就是重新审议请愿书。正如你在此指出的，FCC自己的工作人员最初裁定，当波诺说“F-ing brilliant”时，它没有任何性含义，因此，它并不不雅。是委员们，那些最高层的人，在游说团体的敦促下回去重开了此案，宣布“F-ing brilliant”意味着性。我们确实询问了我们在芝加哥采访的9到12岁的孩子，波诺用“F-ing brilliant”这句话可能是什么意思。他们中没有人像委员们那样看待它。
Well, I think he meant that it was a really great award that he got.
嗯，我想他是指他得到的那个奖项真的非常棒。
Yeah, I think he was just really happy and wanted to express his feelings.
是的，我想他只是真的很高兴，想表达他的感受。
It's a word that you use when you're either very something. If you're very happy, I guess you'd use that. If you're very sad, or very angry at someone, you'd use that. He was very proud of his award. And he was exaggerating brilliant by just using F-ing.
这是一个当你非常什么的时候使用的词。如果你非常高兴，我想你会用那个。如果你非常悲伤，或者对某人非常生气，你也会用那个。他为他的奖项感到非常自豪。他只是用了F开头的词来夸大“brilliant”。
Recent decisions by the FCC are about more than just the F-word. In the Bono decision, the FCC explicitly puts broadcasters on notice that it is changing the legal definition of profanity. In the past, the Commission gave some weight to the idea of context. The F-word and other potentially offensive material could sometimes be allowed on the air, if it was in a context that had some redeeming value, if it was in a news report, for instance. But with these recent decisions, the FCC has moved the line on where context counts. Now they're saying the rule is, if a word is deeply offensive to some members of the public, or the Commission thinks that hearing the word might enlarge a child's vocabulary, that could be enough to overrule context.
FCC最近的决定不仅仅是关于F开头的词。在波诺的决定中，FCC明确通知广播公司，它正在改变亵渎语言的法律定义。过去，委员会对“语境”这一概念给予了一定重视。F开头的词和其他潜在的冒犯性材料有时可以在广播中播出，如果它处于某种有补救价值的语境中，例如，如果它是在新闻报道中。但随着这些最近的决定，FCC已经移动了语境起作用的界限。现在他们说规则是，如果一个词对部分公众成员来说是极其冒犯的，或者委员会认为听到这个词可能会扩大孩子的词汇量，那这就足以否决语境了。
So the line has moved, though exactly where it has moved to is not totally clear yet. For instance, the Bono decision declared that now even euphemisms for the F-word, which presumably include the phrase "the F-word," are probably illegal most of the time. In our interview, John Cody of the FCC made a point of saying that context does still count lots of times. He pointed to page five of the Bono decision, where the commissioners specifically say that if there is quote, "political, scientific, or independent value," the stuff you're broadcasting might be OK.
所以界限已经移动了，尽管它究竟移到了哪里还不完全清楚。例如，波诺的决定宣布，现在即使是F开头的词的委婉语，推测包括“the F-word”这个短语，在大多数时候也可能是非法的。在我们的采访中，FCC的约翰·科迪指出，语境在很多时候仍然起作用。他指出了波诺决定案的第五页，委员们明确表示，如果存在引用“政治、科学或独立价值”，你播出的东西可能是可以接受的。
There is still wiggle room now. For instance, we did not overrule the Branson case, which is an old, I believe, NPR case with the Gotti tapes, in which he uses the F-word over and over, and--
现在仍然有回旋余地。例如，我们没有推翻布兰森案，那是一个老的，我相信是NPR的一个案子，关于戈蒂的录音带，他在里面一遍又一遍地使用F开头的词，并且——
Yeah, let's just explain what that is. That's a case where NPR had a wiretap of John Gotti, and used it in a news report-- this is back in the '80s-- and didn't beep out the F-word. And someone complained to the FCC. And the FCC said, no, no, no, it's OK in this context, because there's a clear news value to this. And you're saying that this decision did not overturn that?
是的，让我们解释一下那是什么。那是一个NPR有约翰·戈蒂窃听录音的案子，并在一篇新闻报道中使用了它——那是80年代的事了——并且没有消掉F开头的词。有人向FCC投诉。FCC说，不，不，不，在这个语境下是可以的，因为这有明确的新闻价值。你是说这个决定没有推翻那个案子？
That's right. That's still good law, in fact. And I think what the decision really stands for, at the end of the day, is gratuitous uses that don't have a newsworthy reasoning behind them are more in the indecent camp than not.
没错。事实上，那仍然是有效的法律。而且我认为该决定最终真正代表的是，那些背后没有新闻价值支持的无端使用，比不不雅更倾向于被列入不雅阵营。
One of the things that's happening is that I think a lot of broadcasters are having to guess what's going to be OK under the law since the Bono ruling. Recently, another public radio show, Fresh Air, faced this decision where there's a singer named Nellie McKay who uses the word "suck" in a song, and not in a sexual connotation, more in a connotation like, that sucked, sort of thing.
正在发生的事情之一是，我认为许多广播公司自波诺裁决以来不得不猜测法律下什么是可以接受的。最近，另一个公共广播节目，《Fresh Air》，面临这样一个决定，有一个名叫内莉·麦凯的歌手在一首歌中使用“suck”这个词，而不是性含义，更多的是像“that sucked（那太烂了）”这种含义。
S-U-C-K.
S-U-C-K。
Yeah. And the producer of Fresh Air went to the lawyers for, you know, and they basically said, are we OK? And they said, absolutely not. That's just too risky.
是的。《Fresh Air》的制作人去找律师，你知道，他们基本上问，我们没问题吧？他们说，绝对不行。那太冒险了。
Yeah. My personal opinion is, I think that's a little bit of an overreaction on the broadcaster's side, while understandable. Again, they take these things very seriously. And they have to first and foremost think about their audience and their licenses. And they don't want to put them at risk. And I understand that.
是的。我个人的观点是，我认为广播公司方面有点过度反应了，虽然可以理解。再次重申，他们非常认真地对待这些事情。他们必须首先考虑他们的观众和他们的执照。他们不想让他们陷入危险。我理解这一点。
You know, I hear this a lot from the broadcast community, which is, just tell us what the rules are. Show us, give us bright line rules. But I don't know that you want the government to write a Red Book on what you can say and not say. I just think that that gets into a very dangerous situation.
你知道，我经常从广播界听到这个，那就是，告诉我们规则是什么。展示给我们看，给我们明确的界限规则。但我不知道你是否希望政府写一本关于你可以说什么、不能说什么的红宝书。我只是觉得这会陷入一个非常危险的境地。
But on the other hand, not issuing a Red Book and saying-- it also does a kind of damage, because people are forced to guess and tend to-- they'll overreach, as in this case.
但另一方面，不发布红宝书并说——它也造成了一种损害，因为人们被迫猜测并倾向于——他们会越界，正如在这个案子中一样。
Well, that might be right. And like you said, it's overreaching. I think with time, what is likely to happen is you're going to see the Commission do the opposite, which is it's going to deny some of these cases and give broadcasters more and more precedent by which to go by over time.
嗯，那可能是对的。就像你说的，这是越界。我认为随着时间的推移，很可能会发生的是，你会看到委员会做相反的事情，也就是它会否决其中一些案件，并随着时间的推移给广播公司提供越来越多的先例来参考。
When the decision says political, scientific, or independent value, could independent value also be literary value?
当决定说政治、科学或独立价值时，独立价值也可以是文学价值吗？
Of course, of course.
当然，当然。
That's funny, because there's a David Sedaris story that we ran on our show years ago, that takes place in a bathroom, that violates all three of the FCC criteria for indecency. It's explicitly graphic in talking about excretory activities, which is one of the criteria. He repeats and dwells on the descriptions at length, because he's trying to be funny.
这很有趣，因为大卫·塞达里斯几年前在我们的节目中播过一个故事，发生在浴室里，违反了FCC所有三项不雅标准。它在谈论排泄活动时非常图形化，这是标准之一。他反复且详尽地描写这些，因为他试图变得滑稽。
And he absolutely means to pander and shock. That's the joke of it, in a way. So it violates all three standards. And my understanding was that today, we really could get in trouble for that, because context might not protect us.
而且他绝对是有意迎合和震惊。某种程度上，这就是笑点所在。所以它违反了所有三个标准。我原本以为今天我们真的会因此惹上麻烦，因为语境可能保护不了我们。
Well, again, I think we would look at the context. But I think you might have given away the-- again, I'm not familiar with it-- but you might have given away the context, in that he's trying to be funny, as opposed to be-- is he talking about Irritable Bowel Syndrome in a health-conscious way, or is he just trying to crack jokes? I think that's the distinction, that--
嗯，再次重申，我认为我们会看看语境。但我认为你可能已经把——再次重申，我不熟悉它——但你可能已经放弃了语境，因为他试图变得滑稽，而不是——他是在以健康意识的方式谈论肠易激综合症，还是他只是想讲笑话？我认为这是区别，那——
Can I play this for you? It's only two minutes long. And if at the end of it, you feel like, oh, you can't actually--
我可以为你播放这个吗？只有两分钟长。如果听完后，你觉得，噢，你真的不能——
Yeah, I'm not going to be able to. But again, I'l let you play it.
是的，我恐怕没法播放。但再次重申，我会让你播放它。
All right. Let me play it and then see if you have anything you can say about it. Here we go.
好的。让我播放它，看看你是否有话要说。开始吧。
We had Easter dinner at John's house, a big afternoon meal which we ate in his backyard. Everyone had taken their places at the table when I excused myself to visit the bathroom. And there, in the toilet, was the absolute biggest turd I have ever seen in my life. No toilet paper or anything, just this thick and coiled specimen. I flushed the toilet, and the big turd [? rousted ?] around. It budged and bobbed a little, but that was it. This thing wasn't going anywhere.
我们在约翰家吃复活节晚餐，这是一顿我们在他后院吃的丰盛午餐。每个人都在餐桌上就座时，我告假去洗手间。就在那儿，马桶里有我一生中见过的绝对最大的大便。没有厕纸什么的，只有这种厚厚的盘绕标本。我冲了厕所，大便在里面绕来绕去。它移动并浮动了一点，但仅此而已。这东西哪儿也没去。
Just then, someone knocked on the door, and I started to panic. Just a minute! At an early age, my mother sat me down and explained that everyone has bowel movements. "Everyone," she said, "even the President and his wife. Everyone in the world. Everyone but me." And I could picture them all, everyone from Red Skelton to Ladybird Johnson. But something this big-- just a minute!
就在这时，有人敲门，我开始恐慌。“稍等一下！”我很小的时候，母亲曾坐下来解释说每个人都会排便。“每个人，”她说，“即使是总统和他的妻子。世界上的每个人。除了我。”我可以想象他们所有人，从雷德·斯克尔顿到伯德·约翰逊夫人。但这东西这么大——“稍等一下！”
And I seriously considered lifting this turd out of the toilet and tossing it out the window. I honestly considered it. But John lives on the ground floor, and a dozen people were seated at a picnic table 10 feet away. And these were people who would surely investigate and gather 'round. And there I'd be, trying to explain that it wasn't mine. But why would I bother throwing it out the window if it wasn't mine? No one would have believed me. Just a minute! And I scrambled for the plunger and used it to break the turd into manageable pieces. And even then, I had to flush twice just to get rid of it.
我认真考虑过把这个大便从马桶里捞出来，从窗户扔出去。我真的考虑过。但约翰住在底层，十几个人坐在10英尺外的野餐桌旁。这些人肯定会调查并围过来。到时候我就得站在那儿，试图解释这不是我的。但如果不是我的，我为什么要费心把它扔出窗外？没人会相信我的。 “稍等一下！”我摸索着皮搋子，用它把大便弄碎成易于处理的小块。即便如此，我也必须冲两次才能把它弄走。
It was Janet at the door, and she said, well, it's about time. And I was left thinking that the person who left the huge turd had no problem with it, so why did I? And later, at the table, I examined each guest, trying to figure who was capable.
门外是珍妮特，她说：“好吧，真是时候。”我心想，那个留下巨大大便的人一点都不觉得有问题，那为什么我会呢？后来，在餐桌上，我审视了每一位客人，试图找出谁有这个能力。
Anyway.
总之。
It's hard to say. But it goes back to that it's an area in which there is a lot of gray.
很难说。但这归结为这是一个有很多灰色地带的领域。
See, but I would argue this one on just straight-up literary merit. If you think about the mission of literature, it's to describe situations that we all can relate to and have had some feeling of ourselves, or can imagine having a feeling of. And that seems to be what he's doing.
看，但我会仅仅从文学价值上为这一点辩护。如果你想想文学的使命，那就是描述我们都能产生共鸣、自己有过某种感觉，或者可以想象有那种感觉的情况。而他似乎正在做的就是这些。
I don't disagree with you. And we would take that segment that you had just produced. And the reason you add it is for, in part, news value, right? You're conducting an interview with a public official, and you're trying to explain to your audience the state of indecency law. Again, that would be factors we would have to take into consideration.
我不同意你。我们会采用你刚才制作的那部分。你添加它的原因在一定程度上是新闻价值，对吧？你正在采访一位公职人员，你试图向你的观众解释不雅法律的状况。再次重申，那将是我们必须考虑的因素。
Those are the types of things that I think the Commission has, and will continue to take, in consideration when we talk about context. We're outside of the isolated word, gratuitous use of the F-word here. We're in that gray area, and I would say in an area of the gray that traditionally has been more on the not indecent side than indecent before.
这些是我认为委员会已经并将继续在谈论语境时考虑的事情。我们这里是在孤立词、无端使用F开头的词之外。我们是在那个灰色地带，我会说在一个传统上比起不雅，更倾向于非不雅侧的灰色地带。
But also thinking about what the Supreme Court says, the Supreme Court says, well, another problem is teaching a kid a word. If we teach a kid a word, then that's a problem. But in this, I don't think any kid would be learning any words from this. And in fact, I have to say this is a little monologue that a seven-year-old would love.
但也要想想最高法院怎么说，最高法院说，嗯，另一个问题是教孩子一个词。如果我们教孩子一个词，那是个问题。但在这个故事中，我不认为任何孩子会从中学到任何词。事实上，我必须说这是一个七岁孩子会喜欢的独白。
There's no question. Again, you're right to be questioning. At the end of the day, what I think you're really questioning is the foundations of these rules, and do they make sense for that medium? And I think that's the right question. And my personal perspective is, I stand not just beside you, but behind you on that one, and in front of you.
毫无疑问。再次重申，你质疑得对。归根结底，我认为你真正质疑的是这些规则的基础，它们对那种媒介有意义吗？我认为这是一个正确的问题。我个人的观点是，在这个问题上，我不只是站在你身边，我还站在你身后，以及你面前。
Well, so in a way, the best thing that can happen for the status of the law, and I sort of hate to say this, is that people would write in right now at your website, would go to www.fcc.gov and basically complain against me on this Sedaris thing. And that's the only way we would get a ruling that would define the law.
嗯，所以在某种程度上，对法律状况最好的事情是——我有点讨厌这么说——就是人们现在就在你们的网站上写信，去www.fcc.gov，基本上投诉我这件塞达里斯的事。这是我们得到一个能定义法律的裁决的唯一途径。
Certainly on that particular incident, I think that's right. If the Commission were to come out and say, no, that wasn't indecent, then that would go in the ledger of those cases of, OK, well, this is seemingly OK. Are these things more like this case, or are they more like the Bono case?
在那个特定的事件上，我认为那是对的。如果委员会出来说，不，那不是不雅的，那么那将被列入那些案件的记录中，“好的，好吧，这些似乎是可以的。”这些事情更像这个案子，还是更像波诺的案子？
It seems the most likely outcome if listeners complained about this story is that the FCC would not rule at all. The current commissioners are much more exercised about sex than about bathroom humor. And the fact is, we did play the Sedaris story as part of a policy discussion, which makes the whole thing much more of an open-and-shut case for the FCC. It would fall into a more questionable area, and set more groundbreaking precedent, if we just played it on its own, no policy angle at all. There's no telling how that would come out. So.
如果听众投诉这个故事，最可能的结果似乎是FCC根本不会裁决。当前的委员们对性比对浴室幽默更兴奋。事实是，我们确实把塞达里斯的故事当作政策讨论的一部分播出，这使得整件事对FCC来说更像是一个敞开又关闭的案子。如果我们只是单独播放它，没有任何政策角度，那它会落入一个更可疑的领域，并树立更具开创性的先例。不知道那会是什么结果。所以。
There is a bigger question in all this. And it's a question that, weirdly, Timothy Jay's cursing research is no help at all with. The question is this. Let's say that you agree with Timothy Jay's findings that show that cursing does not hurt kids. Well, then what do you do?
在这所有一切中有一个更大的问题。这是一个奇怪的，蒂莫西·杰的诅咒研究一点帮助都没有的问题。这个问题是这样的。假设你同意蒂莫西·杰的研究结果，显示诅咒不会伤害孩子。好吧，那你该怎么办？
I think most of us still would not feel very good cursing around children. Even Timothy Jay tries not to curse around kids, or his students, or strangers, for that matter, even though he's sure that it harms no one. In the same way, I think most of us wouldn't want wall-to-wall unregulated profanity all over radio and television, day and night.
我想我们大多数人仍然会觉得在孩子面前诅咒感觉不好。即使蒂莫西·杰也尽量不在孩子、他的学生或陌生人面前诅咒，尽管他确信这不会伤害任何人。同样，我认为我们大多数人也不希望广播和电视上整天整夜充斥着不受监管的亵渎语言。
The kids we talked to were unanimous, by the way, on this point. They did not want more cursing on radio and television. It gave them an odd feeling, the swearing. Listen to how a group of seven of them reacts when one of the kids, in front of an adult and a microphone, simply refers to a swear word that her mom said. She doesn't even swear.
顺便说一句，我们谈论的孩子们在这个观点上是一致的。他们不希望广播和电视上有更多的诅咒。这给他们一种奇怪的感觉，那种咒骂。听听当七个孩子中的一个在成年人和麦克风面前提到她妈妈说的一个脏话时，他们一群人是如何反应的。她甚至没有咒骂。
She runs a day care. And then she had said go upstairs before I bust your S-H.
“她经营一家日托中心。然后她说‘在我打烂你的S-H（屁股）之前，上楼去。’”
Seven kids look at each other, hands over mouths, eyes wide open, in disbelief, embarrassment, giddiness.
七个孩子面面相觑，手捂住嘴，眼睛睁大，难以置信，尴尬，晕眩。
[LAUGHTER]
【笑声】
Then--
然后——
[LAUGHTER]
【笑声】
When these 9 to 12 year olds talked about how they thought that swearing was bad, it was not in a way where it seemed like they were parroting things adults told them.
当这些9到12岁的孩子谈论他们认为咒骂很坏时，并不是那种看起来像是在鹦鹉学舌大人告诉他们的事情的方式。
Well, I just don't see what the horrible deal is with swearing. But in my opinion, I wouldn't want my grandparents to hear swear words. If we were in a car, and the radio, I wouldn't mind it. But I wouldn't want my grandpa, my grandma to hear the lyrics and the music that I like to listen to.
嗯，我只是没看出咒骂有什么大不了的。但在我的意见中，我不希望我的祖父母听到脏话。如果我们在车里，收音机，我不介意。但我不想让我的爷爷、奶奶听到我喜欢的音乐里的歌词。
Why wouldn't you want them to hear it?
为什么你不想让他们听到？
Because it's inappropriate. It might upset them. It might, you know, why does he know these words? Why are we listening to this music?
因为这不合适。这可能会让他们不安。它可能会，你知道，“为什么他知道这些词？为什么我们在听这种音乐？”
So it kind of comes down to being polite?
所以这归结为礼貌吗？
Yeah, because some people are really offended. There's a lot of people out there who take that really, really, really strongly.
是的，因为有些人真的很被冒犯。外面有很多人非常、非常、非常强烈地看待这一点。
A more sensible FCC policy might start right here. Instead of getting all hysterical about the harm that bad words are supposedly doing to innocent young psyches, we could all just agree as a country that some channels on radio and television should be as curse-free as possible. Not because it's healthier for anyone, not because we want to avoid teaching these words to minors who apparently already know them already, but because it just feels like good manners, because it's polite.
一个更明智的FCC政策可能从这里开始。与其对脏话据称正在对纯洁的年轻心理造成的伤害歇斯底里，我们大家作为一个国家可以达成一致，广播和电视上的某些频道应该尽可能没有咒语。不是因为这对任何人更健康，不是因为我们想避免向据称已经知道这些词的未成年人教授这些词，而是因为它感觉就像好的教养，因为它礼貌。
[MUSIC - "STUCK IN A MOMENT YOU CAN'T GET OUT OF" BY U2]
【音乐 - U2的《Stuck in a Moment You Can't Get Out Of》】
Coming up, if Ronald Reagan and Mikhail Gorbachev could be polite to each other, send each other handwritten notes, joke around, why can't Democrats and Republicans in New Jersey do it? Or men and women, well, lots of places?
接下来，如果罗纳德·里根和米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫可以互相礼貌，互相发送手写笔记，开玩笑，为什么新泽西州的民主党人和共和党人不能呢？或者男人和女人，嗯，很多地方？
[MUSIC - "STUCK IN A MOMENT YOU CAN'T GET OUT OF" BY U2]
【音乐 - U2的《Stuck in a Moment You Can't Get Out Of》】
That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
稍后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际公司，当我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week in our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, propriety, stories of people trying to keep a sense of decency and decorum in new and difficult situations. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two: Dems Gone Wild.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你各种关于那个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，礼仪，讲述人们试图在新的、困难的情况下保持体面和庄重感的故事。我们到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕：失控的民主党人。
Ken Kurson had been around politics, but he had never actually run for office. He works with Rudolph Giuliani, co-authored Giuliani's book, Leadership, with him. And last year, Ken Kurson entered the political mosh pit himself. He ran for state assembly as a Republican in New Jersey's 34th district.
肯·库森在政治圈打拼过，但他从未真正参加过公职竞选。他与鲁道夫·朱利亚尼一起工作，与他共同撰写了朱利亚尼的书《领导力》。去年，肯·库森自己也进入了政治的泥潭。他以共和党人的身份在新泽西州第34选区竞选州议员。
Democrats dominate Jersey politics in a way that seems almost quaint to most of us who live in other states. Democrats control both houses of the state assembly, and the governor's mansion. And there hasn't been a Republican senator from New Jersey in over 30 years. Ken Kurson's district is overwhelmingly Democratic. It includes the town of East Orange, where Al Gore beat George Bush by a 40 to 1 margin.
民主党人在新泽西州政治中占据主导地位的方式，对于我们大多数居住在其他州的人来说似乎几乎古色古香。民主党控制着州议会两院和州长官邸。而且30多年来新泽西州一直没有出现过共和党参议员。肯·库森的选区是压倒性的民主党。它包括东奥兰治镇，在那里阿尔·戈尔以40比1的优势击败了乔治·布什。
I knew this race would be just about impossible. Not only have I been personally unpopular my entire life, but the registration advantage alone was insurmountable. When Rudy Giuliani wrote a check for the campaign, he asked me, who should I make this out to, sacrificial lamb? So I wasn't getting into the race with any delusions about winning. But I did welcome the opportunity to shine a light on what I thought were some overlooked issues in New Jersey: property taxes, illegal campaign contributions, and public officials who hold multiple public jobs.
我知道这场竞选几乎是不可能的。我不但一生中个人不受欢迎，而且选民注册的优势本身就是不可逾越的。当鲁迪·朱利亚尼为竞选开出一张支票时，他问我，“我应该把这个写给谁，牺牲的羔羊？”所以我在没有赢得竞选的错觉下参加了竞选。但我确实欢迎这个机会，来照亮我认为在新泽西州被忽视的一些问题：房地产税、非法竞选捐款，以及担任多项公职的公职人员。
Going in, I realized that if I managed to make it a race, my opponents would do whatever they could to make things difficult. I expected disagreement, apathy, maybe even anger. But what I hadn't realized was how darn uncivil my town could get. The vitriol and nastiness that would come from my own neighbors caught me off guard. In my own hometown, Montclair, plenty of residents are so sure of the correctness of their opinions, so convinced that their little voices in the wilderness are the only thing protecting this great democracy from the Bush-Cheney-Rumsfeld-Aschroft-Wolfowitz-Scalia cabal, so righteous in their indignation over the fact that a town son would dare call himself a Republican, that the gloves are way off.
进入选战时，我意识到如果我能让它成为一场竞赛，我的对手会尽其所能把事情搞砸。我预料到了分歧、冷漠，甚至愤怒。但我没意识到我的城镇会变得多么不礼貌。邻居们表现出的刻薄和尖酸让我措手不及。在我自己的家乡蒙特克莱尔，大量的居民如此确信他们观点的正确性，如此坚信他们荒野中的小声音是保护这个伟大民主国家免受布什-切尼-拉姆斯菲尔德-阿什克罗夫特-沃尔福威茨-斯卡利亚阴谋集团侵害的唯一力量，如此义愤填膺，因为城镇的一个儿子敢于称自己为共和党人，以至于他们完全撕下了面具。
In late August, I campaigned at the train station a block from my house. Now if you ever want to feel like a douchebag, I recommend concluding eight years of anonymously riding the train by suddenly interrupting your neighbors to talk New Jersey politics. By that point, I'd done this kind of retail campaigning hundreds of times in all five towns of the district, from the scariest all-night chicken joint in East Orange to the toniest country club in Glen Ridge. I'm not someone who finds it easy to introduce myself to strangers. Yeah, I know, a liability for a political candidate. Luckily, everybody was polite and even interested in talking over some issue or other.
8月下旬，我在我家街区的一个火车站进行竞选活动。现在，如果你想感受一下像个混蛋，我建议你结束八年匿名乘坐火车的经历，突然中断邻居们的谈话来讨论新泽西政治。到那时，我已经在这个区的全部五个城镇进行了数百次这种零售式的竞选活动，从东奥兰治最吓人的通宵鸡肉店到格伦里奇最昂贵的乡村俱乐部。我不是一个觉得向陌生人介绍自己很容易的人。是的，我知道，这对政治候选人来说是个负担。幸运的是，每个人都很有礼貌，甚至有兴趣讨论某个问题。
Plenty of people asked tough questions or challenged my positions. Most voters in my district are Democrats, after all. But I never, not even once, encountered anything uncivil. Even those who clearly had no intention of voting for me were courteous. And I was genuinely grateful when someone would say, no thank you, and save me the time and money of handing them a piece of literature or a Kurson for Assembly pen.
很多人提出了尖锐的问题或挑战了我的立场。毕竟，我选区的大多数选民都是民主党人。但我从没，甚至一次也没有遇到过任何不礼貌的事情。即使是那些显然没有打算投票给我的人也很有礼貌。当有人说“不，谢谢”并为我节省了分发宣传资料或库森竞选钢笔的时间和金钱时，我真的非常感激。
But that day in August at the train station, one woman saw me standing there and started yelling at me. I mean top of her lungs, pop out crazy eyes. "Republicans are evil! You ought to be ashamed of yourself!" Stunned, I managed to stammer, "Why are you speaking to me like this?" She pointed to the embarrassing little name tag that all candidates wear and said, "You wearing that badge gives me the right to yell at you. You're killing innocent Iraqis!" Um, I guess you won't be needing a pen.
但那一天在火车站，一个女人看到我站在那里，开始对我大喊大叫。我是说用尽全力，双眼发狂地瞪着。“共和党人是邪恶的！你应该为自己感到羞耻！”震惊之余，我结结巴巴地说：“你为什么用这种方式跟我说话？”她指着所有候选人佩戴的尴尬的小胸章说：“你戴着那个徽章给了我向你大喊大叫的权利。你在杀害无辜的伊拉克人！”嗯，我猜你不需要钢笔了。
I wish I could report that this was an isolated incident. But it wasn't. The next time was at the Bluestone Cafe, a home away from home where I'd have breakfast several times a week. In the middle of September, the Sunday New York Times ran a long profile of my candidacy, headlined "One Montclair Republican Looks Strong." The piece was a total Valentine. The photo even managed to obscure my bald spot.
我希望我能说这只是孤立事件。但不是。下一次是在蓝石咖啡馆，那是我的第二个家，我每周去那儿吃好几次早餐。九月中旬，《纽约时报》的周日版刊登了一篇关于我参选的长篇个人资料，标题是“一位蒙特克莱尔共和党人看起来很强”。这篇文章完全是情书。照片甚至设法掩盖了我的秃斑。
It was a home run for the campaign and the day after it ran, my team met at the Bluestone to savor it. A bunch of the regulars congratulated me on the coverage. And then a woman sauntered up to our table and said, "Are you the one who's running for office?" "Why, yes, ma'am, I'm Ken Kurson. And I'd like to earn your support on November--" "I would never vote for you. And I can't believe there are Republicans in my town." She pronounced the word "Republican" the way one describes symptoms of Irritable Bowel Syndrome.
这对竞选来说是一个巨大的胜利，文章刊登后的第二天，我的团队在蓝石咖啡馆相聚庆祝。一群常客祝贺我的报道。然后一个女人慢慢走到我们的桌子旁说：“你是那个竞选公职的人吗？”“没错，女士，我是肯·库森。我想在11月赢得您的支持——”“我永远不会投票给你。我不敢相信我的镇上会有共和党人。”她读“共和党人”这个词的方式，就像一个人描述肠易激综合症的症状一样。
All of these attacks on me were one thing. But when people started to question my wife, it became downright bizarre. One time, the woman who heads the Democratic Party in Montclair called our home and yelled-- yelled-- at my wife. "Your husband is a liar. He's trying to trick everyone by not saying he's a Republican. Are you so ashamed of it that you can't even admit it on your mailings? We're disgusted with your lies." Click.
所有这些对我的攻击是一回事。但当人们开始质疑我的妻子时，事情变得相当离奇。有一次，蒙特克莱尔民主党负责人打电话到我家，冲着我妻子大喊大叫。“你丈夫是个骗子。他试图通过不说他是共和党人来欺骗所有人。你是不是觉得太丢人了，以至于连在邮件里都不能承认？我们对你们的谎言感到恶心。”嘟。
This tirade was prompted by one of my mailers that reprinted the Times article in full on one side, an article headlined "Montclair Republican," and on the other side featured a picture of my family with Rudy Giuliani. I'm not sure how I could have proclaimed my affiliation more overtly. But to be honest, I can't tell you how punk rock it felt to set off these little tizzies of outrage: the guy who took my little handbill at the train station and theatrically shredded it in a silent, heroic gesture of defiance, the woman who told my campaign aide that she cannot accept that a Jewish candidate would ever belong to the same party as a Nazi like George Bush.
这种谩骂是由我的一封邮件引起的，邮件的一面全文转载了《纽约时报》的文章，标题是“蒙特克莱尔共和党人”，另一面刊登了我的家人和鲁迪·朱利亚尼的照片。我不确定我还能怎么更公开地宣布我的从属关系。但老实说，我无法告诉你，引发这些小小的愤怒，那种感觉有多么朋克：那个在火车站拿走我的小传单，并以一种无声的、英雄般的反抗姿态把它撕碎的家伙；那个告诉我的竞选助手，她无法接受一个犹太候选人竟然会属于和乔治·布什这样的纳粹同一个政党。
Montclair prides itself on its reputation as a bastion of liberalism and tolerance. Montclair voluntarily funds its own busing program. And Chris Rock joked that a newspaper called Montclair the nation's best place for mixed race couples. The worst place was everywhere else. So what kills me about this particular form of nastiness I encountered in Montclair, and only in Montclair, and only from white liberals, is that it came from people who would be mortified to hear themselves described as intolerant or hostile to those unlike themselves.
蒙特克莱尔以其自由主义和宽容的堡垒而自豪。蒙特克莱尔自愿资助自己的校车计划。克里斯·洛克开玩笑说，一家报纸称蒙特克莱尔是全美混合种族伴侣的最佳去处。最糟糕的地方是其他任何地方。所以，关于我在蒙特克莱尔遇到的这种特定的刻薄形式，只有在蒙特克莱尔，而且只来自于白人自由派，让我感到困惑的是，它来自那些如果听到自己被描述为不宽容或对与自己不同的人怀有敌意时会感到羞愧的人。
In my campaigning in blue collar Clifton and minority East Orange, I experienced many polite no-thank-yous and plenty of passionate disagreements, which tended not to be about Iraq or President Bush, but over the actual stuff New Jersey assemblymen deal with, like tax rates and the state's notorious Department of Youth and Family Services. But not once, not a single time, did anyone stray close to the line dividing discourse from abuse. My campaign even made inroads into Montclair's minority community, especially after I was endorsed by the leader of the town's enormous Christ Church and was the only candidate to address its largely black congregation.
在蓝色领口的克利夫顿和少数族裔众多的东奥兰治竞选时，我经历了很多有礼貌的“不，谢谢”和大量激烈的争论，这些争论往往不是关于伊拉克或布什总统，而是关于新泽西州议员处理的实际事务，比如税率和州臭名昭著的青年与家庭服务部。但从未，一次也没有，任何人越过言语与辱骂之间的界限。我的竞选团队甚至进入了蒙特克莱尔的少数族裔社区，特别是在我得到该镇巨大的基督教堂领袖的支持并成为唯一向其主要是黑人的会众发表演讲的候选人之后。
But when it came to white liberals, how about the aging hippie who lectured one of my campaign's black volunteers on the obligation minorities have to support progressive candidates? When I asked an artist friend, someone I'd been very close to for 10 years, to design a t-shirt for me and my crew to wear in Montclair's 10k race, she refused. She explained that a cartoon elephant was a powerful symbol she could not abide. We're not friends anymore.
但当谈到白人自由派时，那位给我的竞选团队的一名黑人志愿者讲授少数族裔有义务支持进步候选人的老嬉皮士又如何？当我请一位艺术家朋友，一位我交往了10年非常亲密的人，为我和我的团队在蒙特克莱尔的10公里赛中穿的T恤进行设计时，她拒绝了。她解释说，卡通大象是一个她无法忍受的强大象征。我们不再是朋友了。
I didn't win. I did far better than I was supposed to. And almost 2,000 voters crossed party lines to cast a ballot for me. But in the end, the district's two seats both went to the Democrats, as everyone knew they would. The incumbent, a man so dedicated to public service, he also holds three other jobs on the public payroll, and a woman whose chief attribute seems to be that she only has one other public job.
我没赢。但我做的比预期好得多。近2000名选民跨越了党派界限投票给我。但最终，正如每个人所知，该区的两个席位都归了民主党。那位现任者，一位致力于公共服务，他还在公职工资单上担任其他三个职位；而另一位女士，其主要特征似乎是她只担任另一项公职。
Look, there are really nutty people on all sides of American ideology. And I'm not suggesting that Democrats have cornered the market on incivility. That's obviously not the case. Anywhere one party has numerical dominance tends to breed bullies. So the Democrats are bullies in New Jersey, and the Republicans are bullies in Texas and Utah. What's galling is when the Democrats doing the bullying pride themselves on their tolerance, or when Republican bullies cloak themselves in their religious faith, a faith founded on notions of forgiveness and turning the other cheek. Montclair is a beautiful town, but it's not for me. After the election, my family moved out.
看，在美国意识形态的各个方面都有真正疯狂的人。我并不是说民主党垄断了不礼貌的市场。显然不是那样。任何政党占数字优势的地方往往会滋生恶霸。所以民主党在新泽西州是恶霸，共和党在德克萨斯州和犹他州是恶霸。让人恼火的是，当进行欺凌的民主党人以他们的宽容为荣时，或者当共和党恶霸用他们的宗教信仰来掩盖自己时，那是一个基于宽恕和被打左脸伸出右脸的信仰。蒙特克莱尔是一个美丽的城镇，但不适合我。选举后，我的家人搬走了。
Ken Kurson is Director of Communications at Giuliani Partners and co-author of Rudy Giuliani's book, Leadership.
肯·库森是朱利亚尼合伙公司的传播总监，也是鲁迪·朱利亚尼的书《领导力》的合著者。
[MUSIC - "ROCK HARD TIMES" BY EELS]
【音乐 - EELS的《ROCK HARD TIMES》】
Act Three, Swiss Near Miss. Samantha Hunt has this story that, among other things, is a story of manners, of one person acting with complete politeness and good manners, and another person not doing that. Actress Claire Beckmann read her story for us.
第三幕，“瑞士险情”。萨曼莎·亨特有这个故事，除了其他事情外，这是一个关于礼仪的故事，关于一个人表现出完全的礼貌和良好的教养，而另一个人没有。女演员克莱尔·贝克曼为我们朗读了她的故事。
My mother lowers her voice to a whisper, even though we are speaking across a telephone line from her empty house to my empty apartment, barring the slimmest chance that anyone might hear our conversation. Still, she quiets herself, as if to say, the story you're about to hear is too dangerous for broadcast on the regular frequencies.
母亲压低声音耳语，即使我们正通过电话线，从她空荡荡的房子到我空荡荡的公寓交谈，排除了任何人听到我们谈话的最小可能。尽管如此，她还是让自己安静下来，仿佛在说，你即将听到的故事对常规频率的广播来说太危险了。
My mother has never been good with secrets. She used to think keeping them was akin to lying, so the secrets she did keep were special, only for her and my father, kept as a hedge against their children, as a private world for just the two of them, as a reminder of their lives before six kids invaded. This story was one of those secrets.
母亲从不擅长保守秘密。她过去认为保守秘密等同于撒谎，所以她确实保守的秘密很特别，只属于她和我父亲，作为对他们孩子的一种防范，作为只属于他们两个人的私密世界，作为提醒他们六个孩子入侵之前的生活。这个故事就是那些秘密之一。
She decided to tell me out of the blue recently, and she behaved as though it was no big deal. "Haven't I told you this before?" she asked. She had not. But things have changed since my father died three years ago. Now it seems the doors to mystery have blown wide open in my mother's life, as if proximity to the greatest secret of all, namely where my father went, diluted the power of the secrets she once kept. Now she'll tell anybody anything.
她最近突然决定告诉我，而且她的表现就好像那没什么大不了的。“我以前没告诉过你吗？”她问。她没告诉过。但自从我父亲三年前去世以来，情况已经发生了变化。现在看来，我母亲生活中的神秘大门已经大开，仿佛接近最大的秘密，即我父亲去了哪里，冲淡了她曾经保守的秘密的力量。现在她什么都愿意告诉任何人。
In 1964, my mother was a 26-year-old divorced woman living in the town of Pleasantville, New York. In the months leading up to my mother's divorce, her first husband had plowed through dates with a humiliating tally of local women. My mother's first remedy, smashing her car into his when she found him engaged in a passionate Lover's Lane moment with a woman from the Episcopal church, failed to produce helpful results. So she left, joining the world of single women again. Single, but in 1964, not unstained.
1964年，母亲是一位26岁的离异女性，住在纽约州普莱森特维尔镇。在我母亲离婚前的几个月里，她的第一任丈夫在当地女性中留下了令人羞辱的约会记录。我母亲的第一个补救办法——当她发现他在圣公会的一位妇女进行激情的“情人巷”时刻时，把她的车撞向他——没能产生有益的结果。所以她离开了，重新加入了单身女性的世界。单身，但在1964年，并非清白。
The divorce was painful. Her ex became abusive and so she needed a distraction. My mother convinced her friend, [? Kappy, ?] a lady with a large and fierce laugh, that they had to travel, they had to escape. Europe would be a good start. Switzerland seemed safe. Both women were itching to flee. However, Kappy's father, a Catholic, stood in the way. He would not allow [? Kappy ?] to be in the company of a divorced woman until he had first interviewed my mother. This unbearable interview included repeated uses of the verb "to know," employed in the biblical sense. Despite the odds, my mother passed his test.
离婚很痛苦。她的前夫开始施虐，所以她需要分散注意力。母亲说服了她的朋友卡皮（一位有着响亮而猛烈笑声的女士），她们必须去旅行，她们必须逃跑。欧洲将是一个好的起点。瑞士看起来很安全。两个女人都渴望逃离。然而，卡皮的父亲，一位天主教徒，挡住了去路。他不允许卡皮与一个离异女性在一起，除非他先面试了我母亲。这次令人难以忍受的面试包括反复使用“知道”这个动词，从圣经的意义上使用。尽管困难重重，母亲还是通过了他的测试。
That's how they found themselves in the spring of '64 in Geneva, where waves of relief and sudden joy swept over them at each sighting of non-American packs of chewing gum, each pair of funny Swiss shoes, every syllable from a foreign tongue, all the small things that proved the world was not at all small in 1964.
这就是她们在64年春天出现在日内瓦的原因，那里每当看到非美国的口香糖包装、每双有趣的瑞士鞋、每一种外语的音节，那些证明1964年的世界一点也不小的微小事物，一阵阵的解脱和突然的喜悦就席卷了她们。
"We ate fondue every night. We'd never even heard of fondue before," she says. It was at the end of one such dinner when a waiter interrupted their hilarity. "Excuse me, mademoiselles. The gentlemen seated by the window there," and he pointed to two young Swiss men, "have insisted on paying for your meal." "We tried to protest," my mother says through the telephone, "but the men had already paid. And the waiter refused to return the money to them. So we shrugged and invited the men to join us."
“我们每晚都吃奶酪火锅。我们之前甚至没听说过奶酪火锅，”她说。那是在这样的一顿晚餐结束时，一位侍者打断了她们的欢闹。“对不起，女士们。窗边那两位绅士，”他指着两位年轻的瑞士男人，“坚持要为你们支付餐费。”“我们试图抗议，”母亲通过电话说，“但男人们已经付了钱。侍者拒绝把钱退给他们。所以我们耸耸肩，邀请男人们加入我们。”
There's a twist in my mother's voice that is audible through the phone line. "They were extremely polite, manners that American women could only dream of finding back home then. Maybe a Midwesterner could have been this polite, but there were no men like these men on the east coast," she says. "These men held the doors, pulled out chairs, listened intently, paid for everything, and stood each time [? Kappy ?] or I even considered visiting the ladies' room. These were very different times," my mother clarifies.
我母亲的声音里有一种转折，通过电话线可以听到。“他们极其礼貌，美国女性那时在家乡只能梦想找到这种礼貌。也许中西部人可能这么有礼貌，但东海岸没有像这些男人一样的男人，”她说。“这些男人开门、拉椅子、专心倾听、支付一切费用，每当卡皮或我想去洗手间时，他们都站起来。这是非常不同的时代，”母亲澄清说。
"After coffee at the restaurant, the four of us decided to go out dancing. They took us to a magnificent night club. And by this time we had coupled up, [? Kappy ?] and I having decided that she preferred one man and I preferred the other. I got the handsome one. His name was Hans. He knew how to tango beautifully," my mother recalls across the long-distance line. "The men were engineers working for an American company in Switzerland," she says. "Their relationship was that of business colleagues only, not friends. Still, we were all enjoying the night, and so continued drinking and dancing until 2:00 in the morning, when it was decided that what we needed was some fresh air. We thought a walk near Lake Geneva could provide that."
“在餐馆喝完咖啡后，我们四个人决定出去跳舞。他们带我们去了一个壮丽的夜总会。到那时我们已经配对了，卡皮和我决定她更喜欢一个男人，我更喜欢另一个。我得到了那个英俊的。他的名字叫汉斯。他知道怎么跳探戈跳得很漂亮，”母亲回想起长途电话。“男人们是在瑞士一家美国公司工作的工程师，”她说。“他们的关系只是业务同事，不是朋友。尽管如此，我们都很享受那个夜晚，所以继续喝酒跳舞直到凌晨2点，那时决定我们需要一些新鲜空气。我们认为在日内瓦湖附近散步可以提供这些。”
The four set off on an early morning stroll. [? Kappy ?] and her date had a seat on the bench beside the lake, while my mother and Hans kept walking down to the end of the pier that jutted out across the surface of the water. "This was back before you just rushed into a hotel room and slept together," my mother clarifies yet again.
四个人出发开始清晨散步。卡皮和她的约会对象在湖边的长椅上坐下，而母亲和汉斯继续向深入水面的码头尽头走去。“这是在你还没只是冲进旅馆房间睡觉之前，”母亲再次澄清说。
Out on the pier, Hans stood directly behind my mother. The thousand lights of the city reflected off the lake. Romance was nigh, my mother felt. And again, a moment of relief passed through her, thinking of her ex, and then thinking of the exotic Swiss engineer who was just then no doubt preparing to kiss her. She exhaled, and at that moment, Hans placed his hands around my mother's throat.
在码头上，汉斯站在母亲身后。城市的千灯映在湖面上。母亲觉得浪漫临近了。同样，一阵解脱的时刻经过她，想到她的前夫，然后想到那个此刻无疑正准备吻她的异国瑞士工程师。她呼气，在那一刻，汉斯把双手放在了我母亲的喉咙上。
He squeezed. He tightened once. He crushed the cavity of her trachea. Hans wrung her neck thoroughly and effortlessly, as though he were a soldier trained in the exact art of compressing an enemy's jugular.
他挤压。他收紧了一次。他压碎了她的气管腔。汉斯彻底而毫不费力地扭断了她的脖子，仿佛他是一个训练有素的士兵，懂得压缩敌人颈静脉的精确艺术。
No air could pass in or out of my mother's body. She could not move. She could not yell. She could not breathe. She stood staring out across the lake, her arms dangling by her sides, her feet nearly lifted off the ground by the vise about her throat.
没有空气能进出母亲的身体。她不能移动。她不能大喊。她不能呼吸。她站在那儿凝视着湖面，双臂垂在身侧，双脚几乎被喉咙上的虎钳提离地面。
She thought, "This is unbelievable. A Swiss stranger is about to kill me." And then she thought of her life up to that point, as if to see how it could have led her here. She wondered, "Are these the wages of my divorce? Do I deserve this?" By the shore of Lake Geneva, my mother noted the moments that passed. Hans said nothing, only continued to squeeze, as if in answer to her question. Yes, this is exactly what you deserve.
她心想，“这真是不可思议。一个瑞士陌生人要杀了我。”然后她想到了她到目前为止的生活，仿佛为了看看它怎么会导致她来到这里。她怀疑，“这就是我离婚的代价吗？我应得的吗？”在日内瓦湖边，母亲记下了经过的时刻。汉斯什么也没说，只是继续挤压，仿佛在回答她的问题。是的，这正是你应得的。
"The strangest part," my mother whispers, "is I remember the superb mental clarity I achieved as I was choked. In that clarity, I thought, I am going to die now. And the lights on Lake Geneva are beautiful. How sad, I was thinking, that beauty ends here. You really study these things when you think you're going," she says.
“最奇怪的部分，”母亲耳语，“是我记得我在被掐住时获得了一种极好的思维清晰度。在那清晰中，我想，我现在要死了。日内瓦湖上的灯光很美。真可悲，我在想，美丽到此为止。当你认为你要离开时，你真的会研究这些事情，”她说。
Time, that all night had been a torrent, slowed to a drip. After a minute or two of strangulation, she was losing consciousness. She was staring down into the water, when finally, silent Hans spoke. He asked my mother, "What would you do if I didn't let go?" His breath was on her neck. And she thought, "He's breathing." He held the choke a moment longer. He let go.
时间，整个夜晚一直像奔流，慢了下来，变成了一滴水。经过一两分钟的勒死，她正在失去知觉。她盯着水里，终于，沉默的汉斯开口了。他问母亲，“如果我不放手，你会怎么做？”他的呼吸在她的脖子上。她想，“他在呼吸。”他多坚持了一会儿扼杀。他放手了。
That part of the story is awful, being choked by a stranger in Switzerland. But both my mother and I believe that what came next is far more sinister. Rather than screaming bloody murder when she caught her breath, my mother, perhaps out of fear, or even scarier, perhaps out of fear of impropriety, simply turned and walked back to the bench, where [? Kappy ?] and her date sat talking. My mother said nothing. The four of them regrouped, walked back to their hotels, and politely said goodnight.
故事的那部分很可怕，在瑞士被陌生人勒死。但我母亲和我相信接下来发生的事情要邪恶得多。当她喘过气来时，母亲没有尖叫血腥谋杀，也许是因为恐惧，或者更可怕，也许是因为害怕不合礼仪，只是转身走回卡皮和她的约会对象坐着交谈的长椅。母亲什么也没说。四个人重组，走回酒店，礼貌地说晚安。
40 years later, my mother still has Hans's business card. She keeps the card in a bureau drawer filed beside a buffalo nickel her grandfather gave her, a clutch of two-dollar bills she saved, and a tiny red bean filled with miniature carved ivory animals. When I asked her why she kept his card, a reminder of how she almost died, she sounded surprised. "To get revenge?" I asked. "Oh no, not at all," she said. "I keep it because it's part of my life."
40年后，我母亲还有汉斯的名片。她把名片放在抽屉里，旁边是她祖父给她的水牛镍币、她存的一叠两美元钞票，和一个塞满了微型雕刻象牙动物的小红豆。当我问她为什么保留他的名片，一个关于她差点死掉的提醒时，她听起来很惊讶。“为了报仇？”我问。“噢，不，一点也不，”她说。“我留着它是因为它是我生活的一部分。”
That story from Samantha Hunt. Her novel, The Seas, comes out in the fall, and is published by McAdam-Cage. The story was read for us by Claire Beckmann.
那个来自萨曼莎·亨特的故事。她的小说《海洋》在秋天出版，由McAdam-Cage出版社出版。这个故事由克莱尔·贝克曼为我们朗读。
The program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and [? Will Reichel. ?] Pat Tillman was killed in Afghanistan, not in Iraq, as I said in my conversation with John Cody.
节目今天由黛安·库克和我制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、温迪·多尔、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格和丽莎·波拉克。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特经营我们的网站。制作帮助来自托德·巴赫曼和威尔·赖歇尔。帕特·蒂尔曼是在阿富汗阵亡的，而不是像我在与约翰·科迪的谈话中所说的那样在伊拉克阵亡的。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
【致谢】
David Sedaris, who we heard in our story about the FCC, has a new book, Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim. At our web site, www.thisamericanlife.org, you can listen to our programs for free, or buy CDs of them. You can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even the New York Times, all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
大卫·塞达里斯，我们在关于FCC的故事中听到了他的声音，有一本新书《穿灯芯绒和牛仔布的家庭》。在我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org，你可以免费收听我们的节目，或购买它们的CD。你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们的节目音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
【资金鸣谢】
WBEZ management oversight by Mr.  Torey Malatia, who is tired of these things that we say about him at the end of every program. Like he said to me just yesterday,
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生担任，他厌倦了我们在每个节目结束时对他说的那些事情。就像他昨天对我说的，
You F-in' B, why don't you get out of my F-in' face?
“你这个F开头的B，你为什么不从我面前消失？”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。